- The state of 3D printing
today goes two ways,
there's people who are
developing machines that
can print with materials
that we currently
use through traditional
manufacturing processes,
and there's people that
are developing platforms
based on multiple materials.
And this will enable a broad
range of new applications
by being able to
manufacture products
that we were not
able to manufacture
through traditional techniques.
We've developed a low cost
multi material 3D printing
platform that can print
with up to 10 materials,
and it's machine vision enabled.
So we use machine
vision techniques
to enhance, or amplify,
the capabilities
of current multi material
printing technologies.
We call our project MultiFab.
And with MultiFab you
integrate these two worlds
of traditional manufacturing,
and 3D printing.
And by putting them
together you can
create a whole new
range of objects
that we haven't been
able to make to date.
The machine vision system
integrated in MultiFab
allows us to easily
and very quickly
calibrate the printing system.
Second, we use machine vision
to integrate existing components
into that printing process.
So imagine we put
components into the printers
build platform, we
scan the objects,
and then we use that 3D
geometry information to print
the objects around
those existing objects.
Right now a big portion
of the 3D printing kind
of hardware that's available
is focused on printing form,
and on objects for prototype.
The holy grail is
to print things
that are fully functional
right out of the printer,
combining multiple materials
with many different properties,
but also existing
objects that have
some inherent functionality.
We've printed lenses
on top of LED's.
We put this existing
LED into a printer.
We print a Lens.
On top.
Designers and engineers are used
to designing with one material.
So the whole design
paradigm, how we actually
designed products and
objects, will have to change.
And that's going to require
new hardware, that's
going to require new
software, and that's going
to require whole new platforms.
We're going to have to
change the way engineers
and designers think
about design and creating
products and objects.